So hi! Good morning everybody
and welcome back.
So I'm Lee Woodley I work at AAAS
and I'm really interested in both the
technical so I think online tools and
the human so I think people community
managers who really make scientific
collaborations, scientific teamwork,
scientific communities actually function
productively. So I've been invited to
talk here this morning about communities
of practice and as Jeff has outlined
that's really because what we want to do
now for the remainder of the conference
is think about what comes next.
You know we've had these productive,
useful, generative conversations but what
now and the notion of a community of
practice is something that has been
kicked around for at least a couple of
years but we've never really had
explicit conversations about what does
that mean? What does that look like? How
might we actually create that and
participate in it? So what I'm going to
do is I'm essentially going to give you
a ten-minute primer on communities of
practice theory. So the notion here isn't
to be top-down. It's not about saying you know there's a right way and a way that we
can do this.
It's to give us a framework. It's to get
us back to the theory so that we're
thinking about this from the same
perspective and we can use that then as
a way of opening up the dialogue about
what things we might want to use and
where we may decide to go forward from
here and listening to this and going
actually we're not community perhaps at
all is a completely valid response. So
there's no assumptions about the the
output here. So what I'm going to be doing is drawing on the communities of practice
literature. Primarily this is the work of
Etienne Wenger and colleagues so they've
been thinking a lot about knowledge
generation and social learning over the
years and have come up with a lot of
the foundational ideas about communities
of practice and this talk is going to
break out into three key takeaways and
those takeaways are designed to match
along with the core themes of the
conference. So we have models, methods, and measures. So I'm gonna start first of all
talking about methods. So that's the why
why. Why do we need communities of
practice ever? How do we deal with knowledge generation?
How do we deal with the cultivation and
the the use of knowledge? Then I'm going
to move on and I'm going to outline the
model for communities of practice. So
communities of practice have a strict
definition. We think about them in a
particular way so I'm gonna elucidate
that model and drop in a few questions
that might help us start thinking about
what that might apply to to us in this
science outreach space and then finally
the final thing is measures. So really
getting to evaluation and just touching
on this idea of well okay if we do go
down this route and we do decide that we
want to do something more together, how
are we gonna know whether it's working
or not okay? So let's start at the
beginning, so let's start with the
methods and thinking about knowledge
management. So if you think about how
generative hopefully the the past couple
of days have been for you and you think
about the the conversations that we've
had as a result of the lightning talks,
around the tables, in the corridors, at
Story Collider, out on the terrace, over
lunch and you think about what you gain
from that, really we've been iterating
knowledge together. We've been dropping
in our own experiences the things that
we've done, sharing those with others, and
and building on that together and that
really fits in with the five ways in
which we think about knowledge. So first
of all knowledge can't be codified
simply as a static object. So if we'd
given you all a bit of paper or a laptop
and we said write down everything you know about science outreach that wouldn't
really be very useful and if we'd put
that all together in one place that
isn't gonna make any one of us any
better at doing science outreach. So we
think about knowledge as not being able
to be broken down into that single
static thing. Part of the reason for that
is that knowledge as I'm sure you're
well aware can be both explicit so the
kind of things that we choose to codify
in publications, in posters, in
presentations and implicit so the kind
of things that we learn through
interacting with each other, through
having conversations, through talking
about how things are done around here.
As a result knowledge is therefore also
iterative, so like the process
of science itself you know we we may
start with a core set of assumptions,
core set of things that we know but
we're always building on those. We're
always testing them, adding on a bit from
somebody else, trying that out, coming up
with new knowledge and that means that
knowledge the generation of knowledge is
a social endeavor. You know we don't sit
in our dreaded silos and learn stuff by
ourselves. We learn it through
interacting with each other and then
finally for knowledge to be maximally
useful we talk about how important it is
for knowledge to get out of those silos
and actually cross boundaries into other
areas, so knowledge is maximally useful
when we can reuse it and apply it to
different situations and so the reason
that I'm outlining all of this is that
communities of practice, this notion of
them, it has arisen as a way of
cultivating and managing knowledge
together. So a community of practice comes
together around doing and managing
knowledge in these ways that I've just
described. So to end the first section,
some questions. So do we think we need a
community of practice in terms of
bubbling up the various expertise that
we have in this room and beyond the room
for the folks that weren't able to be
here? Does a community of practice sound
like a framework that might be helpful?
And then reflecting on your own needs
and your own expertise, you know, what
knowledge do you have to give and in in
what format? Gow have you most enjoyed
sharing things here? You know maybe you
ended up in conversations about things
that you didn't realize you were going
to talk about and these are things that
you want to take forward and then what
would you like to get in terms of
gaining knowledge from other people? Do
you know what you don't know and do you
know how you might go about finding it
out? Okay so the second section as I say
we're going to talk about models. So I
specifically want to outline what we
mean when we talk about a community of
practice and so venue and colleagues
describe a community of practice as
having three key structural elements. So
they talked about the notion of a domain,
a community, and a practice. So the domain:
this is really what it is we are focused
on. So for a community of practice to be
most effective we need to know
why is that we're gathering. This really
gets at the the purpose, the goals of why
we're coming together as a community and
Mallon gives us an identifier identity.
So we should self-identify as being part
of a community of practice and that
allows us to know why it is that we are
here. That also allows people looking in
from the outside so other stakeholders
who may be interested in what we're
doing
to see that there's legitimacy in that
so we we've created a definition of why
we're doing what we're doing. So one
of the questions that I would ask about
this is is science outreach our domain
or is that too big? Is that is that too
amorphous? Is there too much going on
there? Are we actually talking about
multiple sub communities of practice
focused on different areas, different
types of outreach, different audiences
for outreach? I don't want to presuppose
what that looks like but if we use this
framework to think about this how might
that influence what we we might want to
create after this meeting. So a second
structural element of a community of
practice is the community. So we've
talked a lot over the last couple of
days about reaching out to underserved
audiences, making sure that we're
including all voices in the room, making
sure that we don't make assumptions but
that we listen deeply and therefore we
learn from from everybody that we bring
together. So once we've identified a
particular domain or various subdomains
then we need to be quite intentional
about saying well who do we need there
around that table to help us advance our
knowledge to cultivate our activities in
that particular domain. And then the
final piece as I hope is following on
quite logically is the practice. So
that's okay we know what domain is. We
know who we've got around the table. What
are we actually gonna do together? Just
standing at an online site and putting a
bunch of documents in there that's not a
practice. You know we talked about
cultivation of knowledge through the
ways I described at the beginning,
through interactions, through building
something, through trying to tackle a
particular problem. You know do we want
to work on it so we working on
evaluation models and comparing what
we've each done in our different
projects.
Do we want perhaps to you know think
about writing something together? You
know then
needs to be an activity or a set of
activities which may include meetings,
may include annual conferences, may
include webinars, may include live chats
but we need to be regularly doing
something together to cultivate this
core knowledge base that we have. Okay
so now is section 2 so that's thinking
about three structural elements of what
a COP is and then I promise the final
thing that I was going to end with was
touching on the the measures theme or
thinking about the evaluation. And so one
of the signs of a healthy community as
it gets set up and as it gets to
maturity, is that we were able to be
self-reflective.
We're able to kind of say well is this
working for me? Why am I here? Are we are
we really doing things that are useful?
And with a community of practice then
firstly obviously we need to identify
the shared goals for a community of
practice but it's not just about saying
well are we producing the output, the the
report, the conversations, the thing that
we said we were going to do. So it's not
just about saying you know let's let's
count clicks, let's count comments, let's
count you know what's going on there
because we think about knowledge as I
said as spreading out beyond silos. So if
we come together like at a conference
like this and we share knowledge, what
happens to that knowledge afterwards? So
what are you going to do with what you
learned here? How is that knowledge that
that is being created within a potential
community of practice helping you get
better at your day job or helping you
tell somebody at your Institute how they
could go and look something up or talk
to this other person and learn this
thing? We call now the concept of a
double-knit knowledge organization so
that you're in the community of practice
and we're cultivating knowledge together
but then we take it out beyond the
community of practice and we weave it
into what we actually do in the outside
world. And that creates really
interesting self-reflection and
evaluation questions because we don't
just measure what goes on in the
community of practice in the group, but
we start thinking about what that looks
like out in the world. Okay so that's the
end of the primer that was communities of
practice 101. So what I encourage us to
do and Ben's gonna help us think about
it's like ground this now in practical
reality and
what this actually looks like but just
think about you know as a result of the
conversations that you've had here, what
might this communities of practice
notion mean to you. Were we thinking
about sub projects? Is something has
something occurred to you you really
love to work on and that you'd love to
cultivate together with other people? So
thank you for listening.
I was just wondering um like how do we
build a community without making it
without make putting up extra barriers.
Like when people see oh it's already a
community like I can't join type of thinking? I think there's a there's definitely a
balance to be struck here so we need to
create a strong enough sense of identity
that we I guess a we self-identify as
being part of something, we feel
committed to it, we want to keep coming
back, we want to work together but we
also need to think about you know having
a certain humility that maybe as we
start working on these things we realize
we don't have all the voices around the
table yet and that we actually need to
have pathways through which people can
come and join. So these are not intended
to be static entities. So for example let
me give an example. At AAAS we have a
social media working group meets Monday
morning 11:00 a.m. and that transects
across all the dreaded silos, so it's
various editors, various program
directors, and so on, all of whom don't
have enough time on their own to keep up
with all the changes in social media. So
they join this working group once a week, one, to share current campaigns things
that are going on so that everybody else
in the organization who's online knows
about it but, two, to talk about the
changes. Oh Twitter's made yet another
tweet. Oh well Instagram now lets you do
this and so by coming together in that
group they learn about that thing in a
quick way once a week. That's their
community of practice but the point to
your question then is that's a flexible
domain right. People are going to leave
and move on and do other jobs, new people
are going to join the organization, it's
totally fine that those new hires then
come and integrate into that community
of practice. You know it should be
visible enough that people know where
the front door is and then welcoming
enough that if you have a you know a
reason to be there and something that
you want to contribute that you're able
to come in and integrate with those
activities.
Hi Lou, I'm Kyle from Guerilla Science and
academic stand up. I wanted to touch on
something and I kind of want to bring it
out to the room that you mentioned and
it's the reflective practice and I feel
like I don't actually know how often
people do it in their activities and and
it's different from debriefs. It's
completely different from debriegs and
sharing in in meetings and team meetings
and I'm kind of curious like for you who
straddled the worlds of both UK science
outreach and the US. science outreach
how have you seen it and then maybe in
the discussions that be great to talk
about that. Yeah I mean I think it's so,
what's nice about about this meeting at
least for me from from the perspective
that I'm viewing it from is that we've
intentionally baked in those moments of
reflection here. In the fellowship
program that I run, we do a week-long
training week in January and we cram
their brains full of all the theory
about communities but every afternoon we
take an hour and a half to just let
people think. We create a basic
worksheet of prompt questions that
they're free to use to help or
completely ignore and discard but it's
like think about how their stuff applies
to you and think about how what we are
doing together as a group is either
helping or hindering or revealing to you
things that you hadn't thought about
before maybe even in the way in which
you interact or or try and work with
this information. So I really think
baking in reflection like this, like
coming together and talking about all
those different experiences it is just a
way of giving us that pause to sort of
inhale exhale and then reengage. I mean
again it's it's a structural thing in
terms of how we create it it may be I've
seen it done in various different ways
I've seen some communities have a Monday
work out loud session for example. It's
totally open ended, it's online if you
want you can come in there and use it as
an accountability thing, as an open
reflection thing where you say this is
what I'm worried about working on or
doing this week.
That's a a simple structural way of doing
reflection. The way we do with our
worksheets in our fellows week, that's more structured and more
elongated because we specifically want
them to figure out how to apply the the
learnings back in their home
organizations. We could do this on a
larger scale by coming together once a
year and having reflection baked into
what we are doing as part of that
meeting so it looks like different
things in different places. Stu
Ravnick with UT Southwestern and I apologize
if this question is overly naive. What is
the relationship between a potential
group like this with the already
existing group of NABI and I'm not
trying to be hard about it it just is it
useful to have something completely
separate or is it useful to actually
integrate more strongly or have a sub
working group? Yeah and I think I think
those are completely valid questions and
I would say that NABI is not the only
organization that is thinking about
communities of practice in this space
right. There are there are multiple ones
AAAS convenes one as well. I think
part of this is being quite realistic
about what it is that we as individuals
want to achieve right, that we we are all
very busy people, we cannot be fully
present in multiple different places at
the same time. So it's really about
finding finding your tribe, finding your
people to do the thing that you want to
work on and I personally don't
necessarily think that it matters who
the convening organization is and I
don't necessarily think those convening organizations have to be in competition
with each other and I'm sure they
wouldn't describe themselves as such. So
I think they can be interrelated but we
should also be realistic about not
expecting people to be as engaged in
every location although have visibility
on what is going on in the different
spaces.